foreign
[Music]
so many of us have really Vivid memories
of this crisis
and also the success of the rescue
operation which seemed utterly unlikely
to succeed
I was gripped by what was happening on
the other side of the world the story of
the timeline cave rescue
at the time I was in Thailand and I
followed there was you know pretty close
because it's a miracle
for everything I thought I knew about
the rescue operation I knew the tip of
the iceberg
beyond the headlines beyond the news
stories the first thing that I was
interested in was understanding what it
really took yeah
hello
hello hello hello
this incredibly pivotal scene where Rick
and John first discover the kids this is
the very first scene that we had to
shoot for this movie that first week was
a good bonding experience because we
were all thrown into those scenes when
the divers first to find these kids how
many of you 13 13. they're all alive 30.
yes brilliant
can we go out now
no not today
we do 10 days 10 days you are very
strong
these kids were at 2.3 kilometers in
there
we're live which was really surprising
to Rick and John what day you come and
help us
we have tomorrow tomorrow yeah mood
divers tie divers Thai we'll come
tomorrow with food the doctors and
everything
don't tell me you don't know
they had a real dilemma because they
realized
they wouldn't be able to bring them out
that's what it looked like
it's quite hard to get through into the
place where the boys Drop and it's very
dangerous but that England neighbors
they're trying as hard as possible to
help all of them our safety fortunately
the real divers John lanthan and Rick
Stanton were able to discuss in their
own personal experience directly with
our actors and I was very moved right
there on our first day of shooting to
see how honest how truthful and how well
Vigo and Colin were already bringing to
life this moment that I'd heard Rick and
John talk about myself
my conversations with Rick Stanton and
John belanthan were enormously helpful
to me because it's something that
actually happened and I really feel like
the more I learn about it the more
astonishing it becomes
[Music]
one of the things I always talked about
is this is going to be the point of view
of the British diver so I have the
feeling that the camera are not accessed
in this movie we have to let the
character lead the camera to what to see
we help each other and our course help
us most of the reality is happened in
the cave
which is dark but when people get into
the dark they bring their own blight
sauce you know like a flashlight
so this is become sort of inspiration to
make you feel you are inside what
happened at that moment
the darkness that sayampoo is using the
low light levels it looks so
naturalistic and he really is an artist
he's a humanist and he knows how to
connect the characters to the moments in
a powerful way
this cave which Molly Hughes built is so
real all of the caves were designed
after conferring with the actual divers
so that a production design team could
build the places that were really the
most challenging and so this section
right before the divers reached chamber
nine was always known to be one of the
most treacherous
when we built the sets we had to start
with chamber nine starting on a set like
that kind of helped us begin to answer
questions about what reads best in the
dark how slippery can something be how
sloped can it be how rocky can it be
chamber 9 started answering these
questions for us about you actually have
to paint the rock really dark or it's
going to look fake and it needs to have
lots of depth and Shadow in it to make
sure it looks real
the first time drawing take me inside
the chamber night I was like oh my God
they built the whole thing they built a
cave the condition in the cave the rocks
and all the waters just make it feel
more real you start putting yourself
into the character's mindset this is
what they're feeling and what they would
have thought at that time
Iran is really kind you know he
understands the kids and he helped us
with how to act this scenes that the
rescue divers found us the difficult
things is you have to be hungry you have
to be sleepy you have no energy but you
have hope
these boys had not acted in films before
and I knew there would be a lot of
improvisation so a lot of focus was put
on creating a team spirit and a sense of
trust and the boys were incredible they
were authentic they were honest it was a
very memorable first day of shooting
maybe my most memorable
we should get back
all right
foreign
round brings an enormous amount of
experience an enormous amount of heart
he is fascinated in the human issues at
the center of the story I mean I've been
so impressed by Ron's approach it's a
very complicated story there's a lot a
lot of shots and in difficult conditions
especially the underwater stuff and it's
just a very complex operation
this story is an important story for the
Thai people the Thai people that I'm
working with the actors they've told me
it's important for them because it was
their children there were so many things
that could have should have gone wrong
that it's hard not to view this as a
miracle and I hope people are inspired
by it
people can do a lot of things that seem
a miracle but actually the miracle is
from our hand we have to do it together
thank you stay strong
[Music]